[Musique]
envies de lecture bonjour avec didier
qui mêle bonjour bonjour patrice vous
venez pour un roman qui s'appelle les
roses bleues et qui sous titré si aimé
pouvait se conjuguer au pluriel question
que tous se posent sans doute en va
évidemment en parler on va parler
d'abord un petit peu de vous de votre
parcours parce qu'au fond vous êtes un
jeune écrivain si je me dis je dirais
plutôt que je suis un nouvel auteur
enfin l'écrivain c'est votre erreur du
jeune homme a commis six revirements
effectivement patrice
pourront parler tout de suite pour l'
envie d'écrire elle vient elle est en
vous depuis longtemps lui poserait alors
effectivement il ya plusieurs il ya
plusieurs origines plusieurs raisons
pourquoi j'ai eu envie d'écrire alors
déjà je suis un verre ça y est je suis
né à versailles j'ai vécu longtemps à
versailles et vous avez dit quand on
était jeunes au théâtre montansier
exactement patrice g t d'or au théâtre
montansier j'avais la chance d'habiter
dans un appartement situé dans quatre
montansier et du coup alors c'est un
endroit prestigieux le théâtre vous
savez que il était inaugurée si je me
souviens bien en 1777 et le jour de
l'inauguration il y avait à la faute
j'étais pas encore là louis saez et
marées entre neyret et depuis se sont
succédé dans cette salle de spectacle
des illustres personne enfin et c'est
toujours d'ailleurs une très belle
programmation toujours et est donc moi
j'avais la chance en étant gamin de
pouvoir assister à des représentations
alors essentiellement des
représentations d'auteurs classiques
molière sous tout seul la zone mais
aussi des spectacles plus contemporain
et puis éventuellement aussi des
présentations de quelques artistes de
variété donc c'est formateur maintenant
ça c'est tout à fait formateur et ça
donne envie de moi ça m'a donné une
attirance forte un amour /
les belles phrases l'écriture la variété
de ce qu'on pouvait dire inventer créer
ça ça m'a beaucoup plu et l'autre chance
que j'avais c'est que en habitant au
théâtre montansier j'avais la
possibilité d'accéder directement dans
les parcs du château de versailles
notamment le bassari gestion qui étaient
dans des diagonales à jeu sans
prétention je pense dire que je connais
tous les moindres recoins du château et
donc ça ça m'a permis de d'apprécier la
nature d'observer de
devoir l'art aussi sous toutes ses
formes et je pense que tout ça c'est ça
ma sam imprégnées et c'était une époque
formidable vos mères vous avez donc
rendez vous n'avez pas connu dupont de
ligonnès ou
qui grandissait versailles et j'étais sa
fellation
alors vous avez vous avez alors vous et
publicis et votre vous êtes un jeune
romancier c'est un peu vous n'êtes pas
publiés vous avez écrit un premier roman
roman photo vous aviez huit ans je
coince alors j'ai participé
effectivement dans le casting d'un
roman-photo
utile se dérouler dans versailles et
j'étais le petit garçon bien entendu
d'un couple justement qui vivait lui
aussi déjà une histoire d'amour oui
c'était assez assez formidable c'était
une très belle expérience mes parents me
veut
inscrire on va dire on va dire ça comme
ça et j'avais été retenu dans le casting
c'était vraiment gelé encore ma maman
l'avait gardée pieusement l'époque
avaient été entendus oui tout à fait de
se voir petit garçon c'est
impressionnant
ça se passait à versailles louis dents
au sein du théâtre puis en partie aussi
vers le quartier de montreuil
après alors vous avez fait des études
puis vous avez hésité un moment entre le
journalisme et puis le métier
d'ingénieur que vous allez finalement
choisi vous étiez à la fois de
journalistes les photographes c'est ça
oui parce que en fait pendant que je
faisais mes études
j'avais besoin d'eux d'avoir une petite
activité redire rémunératrice au départ
et j'aimais la photo il se fait que tout
à fait par hasard à un moment j'ai eu
une photo d'une épreuve sportive que
personne n'avait qu'il se dépasser en
religion et donc j'ai eu un premier
contact avec un journaliste à l'époque
les nouvelles de versailles et c'est
comme ça que l'histoire a commencé ma
dit mode culture iphone vous leur iphone
et quelques quelques lignes en dessous
et puis ça n'aura plus le style elie
m'ont demandé de participer plus plus
régulièrement et après essentiellement
j'ai travaillé avec le parisien libéré
il dit sur yvelines matin
et donc j'ai commencé au sport puis
après j'ai eu droit est en charge de
l'actualité j'ai fait ça pendant toutes
mes études c'était passionnant ce parent
était de rencontrer beaucoup de gens moi
j'aime bien le contact les échanges donc
c'était une expérience formidable puis
avec d'écriture déjà
donc vous avez hésité plus fidèlement
dont vous avez choisi de vous êtes
devenir ingénieur
vous ayez d'ailleurs ensuite même
enseigné
le vch qu enfin oui oui alors plus plus
tardivement le but l'institut met donc
j'ai fait une
parcours professionnel que je viens de
citer la en fin d'année 2021 celle dont
je vais me consacrer entièrement à
l'état lié à l'écriture entre autres et
effectivement j'ai fait c'est que ce
parcours dans une grande entreprise
de recherche où j'étais en charge de la
sécurité de plusieurs établissements et
puis je faisais aussi je donnais des
cours dans plusieurs écoles d'ingénieurs
et alger et ce qu plus récemment
effectivement nous voilà un yvelinois
oui attirer aussi parlent parlent et se
doit de le coderc à chose dont vous
parlez beaucoup dans le livre voilà banc
d'arguin et tout ça
mais on va parler justement de ce robot
les roses bleus d'aborder des grosses
bleus on peut s'arrêter un peu sur le
sur le titre parce que vous le dites
dans ton mais ya pas de rose bleu
réalisé dans la nature mais c'est sûr
des roses blanches sur lesquelles on met
un petit procédé chimique qui défend
devenir bleu a effectivement mais alors
ce roman dont on va parler un peu il se
situe dans deux périodes une période
dans les années 80 et puis une autre
plus récente enfin habituel de 2020
à l'époque les roses bleues c'est un peu
si vous voulez quelque chose comme les
tulipes noir les iris rouge à l'état
naturel ça n'existe pas dans la nature
et donc comme passionnément que un
pigment qui s'appelle la delphinidine
enfin bon peu importe voilà ce pigment
il manque à l'état naturel et donc ça
n'existe pas et donc en 1980 dans ces
eaux là on avait trouvé une astuce
c'était de colorer d'ailleurs on le fait
encore pour certains des roses blanches
crème en les trempant dans du colorant
alimentaire et est devenue bleue et ses
roses bleues en fait on en parle si on
fait un petit peu de recherches
historiques qu'on en parle depuis des
siècles alors qu'elle n'existe pas c'est
quand même étonnant il ya tout un tas de
deux légendes de compte qu'ils sont auto
s'est lancé rose bleue et ses roses
bleues est censé véhiculer un certain
mystère
des choses qui sont un petit peu
vous voyez j'ai dit il ya une petite
fille vont générer une curiosité un
mystère et c'est donc voilà ça c'était
un an dans les années 80 et depuis bien
sûr l'homme il peut pas se contenter
l'homme avec un grand h il peut pas se
contenter de rester devant un truc
n'existe pas donc il a fait des
recherches pour essayer de dire mais
comment je vais faire voilà et donc avec
des manipulations génétiques
je rends les australiens les japonais et
les américains ressemblent ils ont
réussi à créer une variété de rose
c'était naturel assez proche du bleu et
notamment dans mon roman j'en parle dans
une deuxième partie ce parti qui parle
de des rhapsodies n'blues notamment
céder des fleurs absolument somptueuse
très difficile à trouver mais aussi très
cher bien entraîné mais maintenant elle
sait le faire grâce à une inflation
élevée alors c'est rose bleue celle sur
des robes vous que vous va offrir marque
à diane où il va parler de ces deux
personnages juste un mot en réalité
diane meur
mon pauvre prestation de solutions
divulguer quoi que ce soit et son fils
va trouver
un récit d'un amour qu'elle a eue avec
un homme qui n'a pas connu lui nation
qui s'appelle le mark cueto scientifique
et etc ce ces deux récits de cet amour
qui composent toute la première partie
du livre
l'essentiel du livre et se marque est un
scientifique qui rencontre et il arrive
acheter une veste d'une veste c'est joli
gazin une tombe sur diane qui est à la
fois
qui plus qu'une voie de salut c'est une
créatrice en train de se moquer
donc il le conseil il est quand même
subjugué par la beauté de cette femme et
lui il est un peu entreprenant un peu
bourgeois rouault et puisse dire il faut
que je me fasse excuser ou savez ils
veulent offrir des déroutes un solvant
bon
alors c'est le début alors qu'ils sont
peut-être qu'ils sont 10 à des marques
alors diane donc c'est une vous l'avez
dit une créatrice de mode une styliste
qui
effectivement
présente sa collection dans son magasin
elle est née à aix en provence l'a fait
des études dont le design dans la mode
voilà papa pas de souci quant à marc lui
c'est un quelqu'un de brillant café
n'est que l'ingénieur qui s'appelle
centrale il ne lui sont pas que très
très jeune et il a été identifié
repérées on dirait aujourd'hui comme
quelqu'un à haut potentiel et donc il va
se spécialiser dans les neurosciences et
dans l'informatique
facile c'est qu'à un moment
il parle du travail des scientifiques je
pense qu'il travaille aussi que pour
donner la parole aux animaux
lisez recherche c'est bon ce roman vous
l'avez compris ligne par de réelles et
puis une part d'inattendu
en fait on n'a pas forcément des
certitudes et y sont établis
définitivement ou c'est bien les choses
évoluent comme vous regardez ce que vous
iliescu faisiez quand j'étais petit
garçon puisqu'on peut faire aujourd'hui
on se rend compte qu'il ya des choses
qu'on imaginait me tarde donc voilà donc
l'idée de dialoguer avec les animaux
c'est peut-être encore du domaine de la
science-fiction toutefois on arrive dans
le roman jeunes gens dit il que bon on
arrive quand même à avoir des échanges
avec certaines espèces animales et à
leur faire exécuter des instructions qui
sont assez simples qui comprennent des
modèles bien sûr bien sûr après le fait
de d'échanger de dialoguer et non ça
fait encore partie de quelque chose d
expérience
parce que d'en parler non parce que on
en a eu effectivement des intrus d'aider
les gens qui ont indiqué qu'ils avaient
la capacité décrypter ce leur disait pas
encore leurs chapeaux des messages
mais honnêtement pour le moment c'est
encore assez lointains comme les
perspectives me semble-t-il c'est pour
ça qu'on est obligé de faire appel à la
fois des techniques disons scientifique
formative tu peux
donc sont deux personnes qui ont une
réussite professionnelle tout à fait ll
est appelé ben oui un créateur italien
avant elle réussit tout à fait bienvenu
mais aussi dans son milieu et il ya une
histoire d'amour assez fusionnelle un
passionnel même qui naît entre eux ce
que j'ai voulu effectivement dans ce
roman c'était raconter une histoire
d'amour alors c'est un sujet un peu
difficile au sens où il ya eu tellement
d illustres prédécesseurs que qu'est ce
qu'on pouvait dire de différents
finalement parce que si je regarde
tristan et iseult romeo juliet le cadre
de vos cd da luz où d'autres là j'ai lu
tout récemment mr
aussi une histoire d'amour un peu
différente métier formidable j'ai voulu
faire ça j'ai voulu montrer
une approche fusionnelle entre deux
personnes qui se trouvent qu'ils se
rencontrent et qui ont envie surtout de
s'étonner de se surprendre pour pouvoir
faire durer la flamme et éviter qu
effectivement comme toutes les histoires
cette flamme s'éteigne petit à petit ou
consomment dans la monotonie dans
l'ennui donc si ça donne je l'étonnement
rendez-vous des surprises qui se font
des invitations des voyages tout cela
est évidemment cela dit raconter
l'histoire d'un couple pour qui tout va
bien qui tout réussit à est
malheureusement c'est pas trés robin
thicke jeux steam donc alors ils
s'aiment et sophie dahl dire qu'elle a
brillé beaucoup de gens qui la regardent
lieu sous les propositions les très
fidèle
c'est un couple sans histoire mais si
j'y restais son histoire évidemment ce
que je dis ça ferait pas alors
mais là alors on ne divulgue h pas non
plus en disant ça puisqu'on sait que
quand le fils découvre ce manuscrit ne
connais pas cet homme ils vont pas
passer leur vie ensemble n'avons pas
passé lorient siens le fait team ans ils
vont arriver à une période un peu
délicate où c'est les fameux s'étant
dont on parle partout et et marque en
plus lui il va commencer à avoir des des
petites perturbations psychologiques qui
va commencer à avoir des petites des
petits soucis de ce type là et sarah
correspondent à une période oui
effectivement il va rencontrer au cours
d'une soirée une personne dont il va
effectivement une femme qui s'appelle
nadia et dont il va effectivement pour
laquelle en tout cas il va avoir une
attirance très forte alors le sous titre
d'utilité si aimé pouvait se conjuguer
au pluriel qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous
parce que c'est une question faut que
tout le monde se pose mais c'est vrai
que
d'ailleurs le personnage de marc dit un
moment bages pensez sincèrement que je
pouvais et mes deux femmes à la fois est
ce que c'est possible
alors là vous me posez une question à
laquelle je ne sais pas répond bien
entendu
mais mais mais mais s'ils s'y est
certain c'est que entre une période
disons anciennes ou les personnes les
couples étaient finalement assez confiné
sortait pas voyager pas travailler
peut-être pas forcément à 2 il y avait
moins de possibilités aux données
étaient aussi plus que
j'ai sans doute qu'on avait aussi
d'autres préoccupations
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
on a tellement d'activités qui nous font
rencontré tellement de gens
c'est peut-être plus difficile un
certainement plus rien n'entend la cdu
dans résidant à tanguer alors il ya
beaucoup de façons sur de divorce vient
s'enquérir des histoires après l'acompte
canton comme dit est ce que ça peut se
conjuguer au pluriel c'est aussi l'idée
que ça pourrait s que ça peut se
conjuguer en même temps est-ce qu'on
peut avoir c'est cette histoire par elle
et alors c'est vrai que l'alien il ya un
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
il ya il peut y avoir la pression de la
société la pression de la morale de la
jalousie
et puis peut-être est-ce là c'est la
vraie question est ce que l'amour peut
se partager ce qu'on peut être amoureux
de plusieurs personnages c'est ça la
question se pose
en réalité
il me semble effectivement le système
éducatif aura alors les yeux et s'est
fait que en fonction de l'endroit où on
est on est peut-être pas tous
on perçoit peut-être pas la chose la
même façon qu'en tout cas dans notre
civilisation de notre société là où nous
sommes là en ce moment il est clair que
il n'est pas permis en prime est
moralement de vivre des défis en même
temps parallèle comme vous le dites au
cours d'une vie s'est étalée dans le
temps en temps pour aller bien entendu
ça va les jouer presque banalité puis
aussi le moins banal c'est des gens qui
restent fidèles l'un à l'autre celle des
socialistes c'est presque l'exception
prévue tout à fait mais c'est vrai mais
c'est vrai que c'est d'aider question
qu'on se pose soit rien il ya il ya
beaucoup de de deux romans ou de 2 ou de
décès sûr qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
polyamour et ses terrasses à cet effet
il ya dans votre livre alors on va pas
entrer dans le tapis ce qu'une petite
vengeance aussi à un moment
il ya des évidemment il ya des scènes un
peu érotique
forte émotionnellement c'est assez
difficile à écrire c'est
d'abord ces scènes érotiques elles sont
vraiment très minime je n'ai pas voulu
mais évidemment parce que ça fait partie
évidemment d'une race jusqu'où on va ou
jusqu'où on ne va pas précisément
moi j'ai voulu garder un grand respect
pour la relation amoureuse entre les
individus et j'ai pas voulu tomber dans
lequel tombe est dans quelque chose qui
soit ont pu refaire ou pornographiques
oui mais bon ça fait partie de vous dire
tous les romans bien sûr il mais c'est
souvent des 17 qui sont peut-être plus
difficile c'est vrai si évident que ça a
pas écrit alors c'est pas ce qu'on peut
vous voir comment on peut imaginer mais
qui sont difficiles c'est assez
difficile à écrire c'est quoi wahlbeck
disait il était très content lui parce
qu'il arrivait très il a une certaine
décontraction pour accueillir les choses
mais bon après chacun son style
sexy je viens cette
question de voile à 2
si l'amour de conjuguer au pluriel ou
pas
il ya quand même même si lorsqu'on
disait c'est à dire que la réalité c'est
un cours sur deux qui divorcent ont un
peu même d'être un peu plus et
y'a quand même le et c'est aussi dans ce
livre le rêve de l'amour éternel quand
même idée il est quand même toujours
présent malgré ça oui je pense qu'en
particulier pour
une très grosse partie du roman tout le
début c'est ça effectivement cédé deux
êtres qui se rencontrent qui se trouve
exceptionnel entre guillemets et qui ont
envie de vivre une histoire qui va aller
jusqu'au bout et c'est simplement parce
que à un moment de sa vie marque je
voulais dinepa n'est pas au top de sa
forme qu'il va rencontrer quelqu'un
qu'il qui va être radieuse et
merveilleuse attirante et les deux
femmes sont très attirantes encore un
café mais le sac alors oui c'est
peut-être nécessaire aussi pour que ça
puisse se produire enfin dans l'histoire
en tout cas bien sûr est ce que
une fois que vous avez eue écrit ce
livre mais en y réfléchissant à ce que
est ce que vous dites qu'au fond tous
des héros dia démarquer ici saura t
oui oui je je je sais un peu plus je
considère effectivement que vraiment ils
se sont ils se sont ratés d'ailleurs à
un moment dans le roman on voit bien il
pourrait se remettre ensemble entre
guillemets et puis les choses ne sont
pas mes mais on voit bien que marc lui
il vit ça vraiment comme un échec même
s'il est complètement responsable entre
guillemets de
l'espace kabyle d'ailleurs à wingles il
le racontera un peu plus tard et à
mahfad culpabiliser et il a des regrets
il a des regrets effectivement et elle
s'est sentie trahie quand même elle
s'est sentie trahie complètement
complète donc donc oui donc cesser cette
histoire raté mais même le au fond le
fils de diane un cantique quand il lit
au fond cette histoire il pourrait
vouloir se marre c'est d'ailleurs c'est
une question que vous êtes posé dans
comme a posé pas mal de rythme sur mon
roman j'ai eu notamment une jeune fille
enfin deux jeunes femmes qui m'a dit m'a
posé la question en me disant c'est pas
possible que kevin ait eu envie de
rencontrer marc après qu'il ait brisé le
coeur de diane
au
contraire kevin quand il va lire ce
manuscrit ça va lui donner une envie
folle de rencontrer cet homme dont sa
mère était follement amoureux quoi
pourquoi et qui est gay c'est qui ce mec
fusionnelle passionnel donc il a eu
envie de la révolte le rencontrer et en
le rencontrant il va il va découvrir un
homme formidable qui a en plus
l'avantagé d'avoir une fille très jolie
très séduisante qui s'appelle laura on
s'est
tous dit que justement c'est hélas un
squeeze et le livre est sorti il ya
quelques mois oui
vous avez déjà des dénis des retours de
lectrices lecteurs alors il se fait que
j'ai beaucoup de lectrices qui ont ils
ont lu ce roman et ils l'ont apprécié
j'ai aussi des lecteurs qui m'ont
témoigné notamment j'ai pris ce fait
j'ai fait quelques séances de dédicaces
et notamment sur arcachon j'ai rencontré
un homme assez formidable passionnée de
lecture qui des milliers de livres et il
y très peu de romans et qui a découvert
mon livre dans une librairie
t'il qu'il a lu puis il a reposé vite
parce que il y
en ait plus tôt fait qu'il a beaucoup
trop de bébés qui la déborde acheteurs
d'or et puis quand j'ai été en des dix
classes sur arcachon il a vu que je suis
passé monsieur dans du journal sud ouest
façon peu importe il savait pas c'est un
article et donc il est venu discuter
avec moi depuis on entretient
une correspondance et c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui mérite si tu as aimé type
à cheveux il ya des coïncidences dans le
livre entre sa vie et le livre est donc
ça lui a beaucoup plu c'est important
pour un
décrivait en ces termes que d'avoir des
idées au four le retour des avis des
lecteurs très important très important
et c'est vrai que les séances de
dédicaces ça permet déjà de d'échangés
ce soit des gens ont déjà votre livre
viennent nous le faire simplement de
vous casser ou soit après certainement
lui l'échangé avec vous et puis et des
outils maintenant merveilleux comme
instagram en particulier ou là les gens
effectivement vous envoie des
commentaires des avis et c'est tout à
fait intéressant on découvre tout un tas
de on n'imagine pas au début quand j'ai
écrit ce livre
je dors je me demandais si un éditeur
allez me le prendre et je remercie
présent le lis bleus qui titille team à
adopter et tu as pris le pari de
d'éditer libre mais au début on se dit
mais finalement tu y vas le lire quoi et
quand on voit que le livre il vit sa vie
et des gens ils vous envoient des photos
avec le livre en situation dans les à
droite à l'étranger et ça ça vraiment
c'est quelque chose de très faisable de
très touchant en est quand même toujours
pour quelqu'un à favori pour être humain
quand j'écrivais c'est aussi je reviens
en arrière un petit peu quand j'étais
petit garçon j'écrivais et s'ils
maintenaient aussi envie de l'écrire je
lisais beaucoup plus à notre époque
enfin on a quelque chose près de la même
génération
il y avait beaucoup moins d'activités
informatiques des jeux il y aura donc là
ce qu'on faisait soit on s'amusait et
moi je vous dis le parc du château de
versailles ou soit on lisait en
particulier et donc que moi j'ai lu la
bibliothèque loza biotech verte etc etc
et puis j'avais une grande soeur qui
elle avait une machine à écrire
remington salle des machines et il est à
nos portes voilà et non j'aimais bien
l'idée de pouvoir écrire des petites
phrases j'ai toujours écrit des petites
phrases haut du buste et j'aimais bien
les taper à la machine à écrire pour
voir ce que ça donnait ça y est c'est
comme ça je pense que ça ça aussi c'est
un événement déjà participé et j'aimais
beaucoup aussi j'aime beaucoup les
citations d'ailleurs dans des mouvements
vous avez vu à chaque délit chapitre je
me suis attaché à mettre une citation
qui est représentative que j'aime et qui
en principe représente le chapitre il
donc j'ai commencé comme ça à taper des
petites choses des petites tâches de
plus en plus long du coup quand je veux
dire des petits coups de gueule sur
l'actualité vous savez quand on vit 16
ans 17 ans 18 ans on écrit des choses
aulas d'ado on se révolte un petit peu
et puis après j'ai commencé à écrire des
choses un peu de plus en plus structuré
de plus en plus longues mais tout ça
pour moi je gardais pour moi merci
beaucoup didier grimé à la salle donc
les roses bleues cette audition
l'édition le lis bleu un tout et tout
est bleu tout ab puis et puis et puis je
crois c'est pas un secret mais phase
aller continuer oui oui je suis en train
d'écrire le le sable on l'a dit la star
d'amour ça va mélanger une histoire
d'âme ans mais ça va s'ancrer maintenant
cette fois ci sur un volet historique ou
un sens en sang dévoilée on va se
retrouver au moment de la seconde guerre
mondiale il va y avoir un
parcours oscillant entre aujourd'hui et
la seconde guerre voilà eh ben vous
reviendrez d en parler avec le grand
plaisir patrice je vous remercie
sincèrement non a invité car vous savez
que un jeune auteur tu n'es pas un
nouvel auteur d'un nouvel auteur il
haïti n'est pas une star du show biz une
personnalité et cetera c'est vrai que
c'est un peu plus compliqué de faire
delà de la promotion de rencontrer des
journalistes et merci sincèrement de
m'avoir invité les roses bleues didier
qui mêle merci beaucoup
[Musique]